c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie tu télécharges l'api
ajouté gris et tente de remporter
jusqu'à un million d'euros sans rien
faire bravo l'auto facile d'être riche
[Musique]
c'est des gants de boxe poids non
sais-tu des maracas c'est des
charentaises qua non de boxe a cédé je
sais ce que c'est c'est d un abricot il
pêche et les fruits d'été des poires ces
deux miches la pop est un avec l'été a
cédé je sais ce que c'est ça c'est des
espadrilles c'est la mode des
espadrilles faut que j'en achète
d'ailleurs la dorsale on dirait des bars
peuvent pas vers ces des espadrilles
j'en ai des espadrilles donc arrêter
quand même je sais ce que c'est donne ma
langue au chat
alors ça c'est des tongs
normal les tombes de mimie mathy nom du
bar je perds du temps à bowie la
perspective est quand même mal foutu la
sueur
[Musique]
à des tombes et c'est pareil j'étais aux
espadrilles une célèbre date